- Thank you so much for
your kind introduction.
I am very excited to be here.
I have never been at Yale before.
I knew it was beautiful
but not this beautiful
and you organized this
amazing, sunny day for me
so I am really happy to be here.
This title might be puzzling for somebody
so let's start out with explaining it.
It really tries to deal with two issues.
One, of course, is related to
the term secondary and copies.
Copies are considered to
be secondary kind of source
with respect to the original,
which is the primary
source on which we rely.
And so, the issue is whether
many copies may in fact
be a primary source as
the original that is lost.
The second issue has
to do with permanence.
Now, thoughts, actions, events
cannot be frozen in time,
they happen and go.
But we can make them permanent over time
if we embed them in a document,
and we can do it because we
want to preserve the memory
of what happened or what we taught,
or because we just wish
to communicate them
that is to make them
cross-space not just time.
And when we do that, in
fact, we generate something
that does continue to be.
And sometimes we want it to continue to be
and that's why we have memory institutions
to preserve the documentary
memory of our time.
But sometimes we really don't
think about the permanence
of what we generate.
We just generate it.
And then it is there, some
place, and keeps being there,
and nobody's getting rid of it.
So, this is the involuntary permanence
of the many copies that
we're generating today.
So, this is what the subject
of this lecture today is.
If you think that this is
an issue of digital times,
it is not.
At the time of classic Rome
the records were written on wax
and they were taken
through underground tunnels
from the offices to the Tabularium
where they had to be put
in a very protected place
because of course everybody
could tamper with wax.
And then manuscripts would make copies,
a multitude of copies.
They were passed on for access to people.
Among these people Cicero
would transcribe writing.
So you see it's a never
ending chain when it starts,
and it started then and it continues now
and we're still finding
copies of documents
that were supposed to have been destroyed.
So, as we talk about Rome, Roman Law.
Most concepts that control
the way we deal with documents
come from Roman Law.
For example, documents
preserve perpetual memory
of facts and acts to which they relate.
Authentication has to
be based on procedure
on how the documents
are generated and used.
The deposit of a document
in a public place
guarantees their reliability
as the testimony of the actions
that the document talks about.
Antiquity gives documents
the highest authority.
Why?
Because obviously they were not generated
for the uses we make up them today.
So you can trust what they say
because they were not tailored to say
what we want them to say today.
Unbroken legitimate custody
ensures document authenticity,
of course, by inference.
This is the Justinian Code.
We have built much of it
on the Justinian Code,
but of course this is a body of law
so laws are made to be broken.
So, the rule of law was circumvented.
It is very easy to go, I
guess, to use those rules,
by for example bringing the
forgery to a public repository
and depositing it there.
It automatically becomes trustworthy.
So, in the 17th century a
Benedictine, Dom Jean Mabillon,
in France developed a
discipline called Diplomatics,
which means about records.
He basically demonstrated
that you can base
the trustworthiness of documents
on the analysis of the
process of their genesis,
on their form, on their structure,
and on the way they are
transmitted through time and space.
So, during those times there
were many judicial disputes
on the authenticity of documents
which were called Bella
Diplomatica, diplomatic wars.
And they were based on diplomatic methods
because, and I quote now the
Bishop of Venice at the time
Balthazar Bonifacio, who said,
"It is so much better to
win by reason than by force.
"So records of documents
are so much better
"than navy yards and weapons."
And that's the way in
which the law of evidence
had origin in the
faculties of law in Europe.
So, by mid 18th century
all the faculties of law
taught Archival Science and Diplomatics
as forensic disciplines, that
is in order to prove the facts
that the documents talked about.
So, then, if you put
together archival concepts
and diplomatic concepts,
you get this field of study
that is called Archival Diplomatics,
which analyzes documents on
their own as individual items,
that's Diplomatics, and in
context among all the documents
to which they are related,
and that's Archival Science.
Now, we can use this science,
Archival Diplomatics -
come forward, there
are lots of seats here.
We can use it retrospectively,
that is in order to understand
what happened in the past
or to understand and identify
the documents of the past.
Or we can use them prospectively,
that is to design the systems
that will generate the
records of the future.
So once we understand what
are the essential elements
of the documents on which
we can base our assessment
or what they are or whether
they are trustworthy, et cetera,
we can embed those elements
in the systems that we design
for the creation of future documents.
So that's the way Archival
Diplomatics is used today.
That's why you have
Janus' face there, right?
The two faces, looking at the past
and looking at the future.
And there are three specific
areas that we deal with
in Archival Diplomatics.
You can see on the left
the concept of record,
so the analysis of all
manifestations of records
through time and form and element.
In the middle, the process of creation
of the documents through time.
And on the right, the trustworthiness.
Now, we want to focus now
on the trustworthiness area
for a moment or more.
Can I move this? Okay.
So, trustworthiness really
consists of three concepts:
reliability, accuracy and authenticity,
which are quite distinct.
So, the reliability is the
trustworthiness of a document
as a statement of fact,
that is as to its content.
It means you trust what the document says.
How do you access reliability?
Normally you base it on the
competence of the author.
For example, if you have a blueprint
and the author is an engineer
you tend to trust it more
than if the author is a
janitor of the building, right?
So, you see, it's again an inference.
I trust the author, I trust
the document, or its content.
And the second element is
the control on the creation.
Not everybody can get into the system.
Not everybody can use that letterhead.
Not everybody can use
the stamp, and so on.
Accuracy is the correctness
and precision of the content.
So, it's really the
data within the content.
And again it's based on the
competence of the author,
but in addition it's based
on control on transmission.
Because especially in
the digital environment
when you transmit a document
from a system to another
you easily get modifications.
Authenticity is the thing
we want to look at today,
in particular.
It's the trustworthiness of a document
that is what it says it is,
which is being uncorrupted
and untampered with.
And we base it on two
very important factors:
on the identity of the
document and on its integrity.
So, what document on?
On which type of document we base it?
Well, we know from
Dimplomatics that a document
can have different degrees of perfection,
and the degree of perfection of a document
determines its authority.
So, if you write a note
without signing it,
it doesn't have much of an authority.
But if you put 20 stamps on
it and as many signatures
and a gold seal, you get the impression
that this document is saying
something really important,
right?
So, there are three statuses
of transmission of documents,
only three ways that a document can be.
Can be a draft,
which a document prepared
for purposes of correction.
It is meant to be provisional,
it is meant to be temporary.
It does not mean that it is not important.
To a historian a draft
may be more important
than an actual original document
that was generated from it.
But it simply means it was not meant
to have legal consequences,
it was not meant to attest to facts.
It was meant in preparation
of something else.
Then you have the original.
The original has three characteristics.
Primitiveness: must be the first.
But it must be the first that
is complete, so completeness.
And must be able to reach the purposes
for which it was generated.
So why do I write there in brackets a fax?
Well, because what do you
do when you have a document
that is the first and it is complete,
the one that you put in a fax machine?
It is unable to reach its purposes
other than by the creation
of another document on the other side,
which is the one that is
effective but is not complete
because it doesn't have
the original signature
and it is not the first.
And this is the reason why procedurally
we always require both the
sender and the recipient
to keep their own part
because together it is an original.
Separated they don't attest to anything.
And you know why, because
the received document
can prove that was sent
by a specific machine
at a specific time.
It cannot prove who actually
put it in the machine,
number one, and what
was put in the machine
because I could fold
three documents together
to compose something and pass it through
and then separate it.
So I can always say I never sent it,
there is no such a document with me.
Especially when documents are supposed
to reach legal effects, you
better keep it on both sides.
So the concept of original through time.
When we think about the
digital environment,
so may people say, "Oh,
there is no original."
Of course there is original,
except it lasts for a nano-second,
because the original is the document
that is first received by
the intended recipient.
You open it, you look at
it, that's your original.
Then you save it,
by doing that you take
it apart and destroy it.
And then every time you recall
it you create a new one,
it's a copy.
But the original exists
even if for a brief time.
Now, through the law, the legal systems
involve the civil law system
and the common law system,
the original is always the best evidence.
So, what happens when we
don't have an original.
We often have lost originals.
And copies are not just
made for convenience
so that they can be accessed by many,
but they can be made for legal purposes.
So, we have different kinds of copies,
and what distinguishes them is
the authority that they have
but also who generates them.
So for example, an
authentic copy is a copy
that is declared to be authentic
that is conformed to the
original by an officer
who has that responsibility.
Cannot be you.
It has got to be a notary,
a lawyer, a professional,
it has to be somebody else, a third party.
So that's an authentic copy.
It doesn't have to be identical
as long as the person
who declares it authentic
considers it to be essentially the same.
Then we have the facsimile.
Anybody can do a facsimile.
You can make a facsimile for exhibition.
What is typical of the facsimile
is that the medium on which
the document is identical
to the one of the original.
It's not just the content.
The whole thing is identical.
If you were not actually announcing
that this was not the original,
anybody could think
that it is the original.
Then there is the copy in
the form of the original.
The copy in the form of the original
is a second original.
That is the same person
who has issued the original
later on issues it again.
So, that means that it is not the first.
Primitiveness is missing.
But the other two qualities are there,
which are completeness,
because it's absolutely
identical to the original,
and effectiveness.
An imitative copy is a copy
that looks like the original
but really it has elements
that make you distinguish it
from the original.
A photocopy.
A photocopy is the typical imitative copy.
A simple copy is just a transcription.
It's when you just sit
there and copy document.
An insert is the copy,
the transcription of a document
within another document.
For example, when you
forward an email to somebody,
what is inside is an insert.
So, it's a document contained
within another document.
An inspeximus instead
has really the same force
as the original and
substitutes the original.
What is it?
This is very typical of old times.
Traditionally in old jurisdictions
for certain legal acts
the record is the act.
No record no act.
So, a contract of land ownership.
You need the record.
You lose the record,
you don't have the land.
Unless you have a system of registry
but that didn't exist in the past.
Or the emperor or the
king gives you a benefit,
the record is the benefit.
That gets in a fire, it's gone.
Or over time they just crumble,
and as they crumble the
owner would go to a notary,
a notary public, or a lawyer
and ask for an inspeximus.
So, the notary public or the
lawyer looks at the document
and transcribes it writing
I have seen, vidimus,
or I have inspected, inspeximus,
the original document
that says so, so, so, and so.
Transcribes completely, signs it,
you can destroy the original.
That is the most traditional
way through which the titles
of old families and cities, et cetera,
have been preserved over time.
Then the other thing
that you have to look at
when you look at copy, in
addition to who issues it
and how much authority it has,
is also the hierarchy of copies.
So, you can copy from an original,
you can copy from the first copy,
you can copy from the 10th copy.
The possibility of error keeps growing.
The monasteries used to copy the text
in order to make them go through centuries
because, of course, paper
and parchment would crumble
and the ink would disappear.
So that was the purpose.
But human error keeps
compounding itself over time.
So, if you have the second
copy that's more authority
than if you have the
10th copy of something.
So that is also one thing
that has to be looked at.
Now, in the digital
environment, let's move on,
those are the concepts
that are at the foundation of everything.
Now we have to confront
what we are dealing with.
We have digitized originals
which as originals were on other media
and we have no problem with them.
They correspond pretty
much to an authentic copy.
You digitize it and you declare
that it is conformed to the original.
All the aspects,
that is everything but the medium.
But all the rest is as
if it were the original.
So there is no problem there.
Born digital originals, we already said,
exist for a nano-second.
So what are we dealing with?
We deal with synchronic copies
that is copies made all at the same time,
for example, when you send
a message to 20 people
at the same time.
We're dealing with diachronic copies,
for example, when you saved
them to an external drive,
or when you make after the time
you regularly copy something
for redundancy so that you are sure
that if something gets
destroyed you still have an item
somewhere.
Or for distribution to
a variety of repository,
the log system.
Lots of copies make stuff safe.
That's the log system.
One thing we have learned
is that all the copies
made through redundancy and distribution
are never identical to each other.
If anything, at least the
metadata related to time
is changed.
Never identical.
The other thing we learned
is you cannot preserve digital documents.
You can only preserve the
ability to re-produce them
or to re-create them,
and we will see the difference later on.
However, in order to re-produce
or re-create a document
you have to have a document
in the first place,
that is you need to have
fixed form and stable content.
What is a document with fixed form
in the digital environment?
Okay, this is a type,
it's a digital entity
whose binary content
is stored in such a way
that what you see on the
screen every time you recall it
is identical to what you have seen before.
That is, the documentary
presentation remains constant,
even if the technological or
digital presentation changes.
So, you can move a
document from Word to PDF.
It's a different digital format.
But what you see on
the screen is the same.
So that is a document with fixed form.
But also a document has fixed
form if the same content
can be presented on the screen
in several different ways
but in a limited number of possibilities.
The same stored entity can
show up in different forms.
For example, statistical data
can be viewed as a pie chart,
a bar chart, or a table.
But it is a limited number
and it is always the same
possibilities and the same data.
Stable content means
that the data and the message it conveys
are unchanged and unchangeable.
So the data cannot be
overwritten, altered,
deleted or added to.
Or it means that the changes
are limited and controlled
by fixed rules
so that the same query
generates the same outcome,
and we have different views of
different subsets of content.
For example, a library
catalog, an archival inventory.
You never see it altogether, right?
You do a query and you see
the entry that you want.
But the same query always will
get you the same response.
So that is still
considered stable content.
When we think about a document
in the digital environment
in terms of fixed and stability
and authenticity, et cetera,
we have to think of three
parts, not just one.
It's not just this item that you pick up,
it's three things that
live quite separately
from each other.
One is the formal
elements of the document,
which are the traditional ones
we see on the face of a document:
the date, the address,
the salutation, et cetera.
The other one is the metadata,
which are the attributes of the document.
Now, the metadata are not an invention
of the digital environment.
We didn't call that metadata.
We call this intrinsic
elements of the document.
Think of some old document folded,
you fold it and put it on the back,
on the dorsum, that is
an endorsement, right?
Which has the date of the document,
the name of the addressee,
the name of who is keeping the document,
the subject of the document.
Those are the metadata.
On the front of the document
what do we write when we receive it?
The date of receipt.
What do we write
or stamp with the name of
the office receiving it.
Those are all the metadata.
The same metadata are
needed in our present
in the digital records
except that they are
transparent to the user,
you don't see them.
On the paper you do.
Digital components.
Digital components are
those stored entities
that are what you actually
preserve or conserve
in the digital world.
You don't see them and
they do not correspond
to the part of the document.
So for example, if you have 10 memos
that are all in the same format
and they're all textual,
they can all be in one
component, one digital component.
But if you have an email
with attachments and
the digital signature,
you have the header, the
message, the attachment,
and the digital signature.
There're five components
that go in five different
parts of the system
and need a different preservation measure.
So, you understand that
here you're dealing
at a completely different
level, with different parts
that eventually to
re-produce the document,
so that you see on the screen,
have to get altogether.
Because what we never had
before is the difference
between a stored document
and a manifested document.
In fact, with a digital
entity we have at least
two documents every single time.
The stored document is
made up of the components
used in re-producing the document,
that is in producing it
again when you recall it,
and they are the data to be processed
in order to show the document,
which are content data
and form data.
The rules for processing them
which are the composition data.
That's all the stored document.
The manifested document
is the visualization
in a form that is suitable
for reading to a person
or to a system.
Now, sometimes you don't
have this manifestation.
For example, you go to
the ATM to get money.
You put your card in there
and something happens within the system,
that is the system is checking
whether you have got the money,
and then decides to give you some,
and then makes all the calculations,
subtracts your money from what you had.
Every single action
generates stored records,
that is content data, form
data, and composition data.
That the system sees
but you will never see.
What you get is the receipt at the end.
In other cases you do not have a stored
manifested document.
But you can re-create it.
Like in a relational database.
So, when you have a relational
database and you ask a query,
a document shows up.
You can decide to save it as
such, as what you actually see,
in which case you have
a manifested document,
you have a stored document.
Or you don't save it because you know
that every time you want to see it
you just go through the same query.
So in that case you re-create
the document every time.
You see you're now re-producing,
you're re-creating it.
Types of digital documents, two types.
Static, the ones that only allow you
to open, close and
navigate and nothing else.
And interactive.
They have variable
content, form, et cetera,
but the rules are fixed.
That is, whatever you do
always you get the same output.
So in light of all the above,
when we talk about digital copies,
what you need to do is to
identify the authoritative copy
because we have millions of that.
And the best way of identifying them,
there're other ways that I will mention,
but the best way is to
look at the metadata,
which are the primary means
to provide authority to a copy
or to identify the authority of a copy.
Okay, identity metadata.
Definition.
Identity metadata are all
the attributes of a document
that characterize it
as unique, altogether.
They make it unique, it's
like your identity card.
It says where you were
born, when you were born,
and where you live, et cetera.
So all those elements,
they make up your card.
This is the same thing.
Identity metadata are unique
together for each document.
And these are the ones that
we call identity metadata:
the names of the persons that concur
to the creation of that document;
the dates, times of genesis,
issuing and transmission;
matter or subject;
relationships; form name;
format presentation; attachments;
and if applicable a digital signature.
You actually don't need anything more.
In fact we were saying today at lunch
that really all you need is the expression
of the relationship to other documents.
Because once you identify that,
then you can go to all the rest,
you can access everything else.
You have the classification code,
like a person has an ID, that's it.
That's the person, from
there I can go anywhere.
So, this idea of having metadata
for under 25 attributes,
it's really not only
non-realistic but not needed.
Integrity.
A document has integrity if the message
it is meant to communicate
to achieve its purpose
has not changed.
You see,
the message needed to
communicate has not changed.
Okay, so we have traditionally said
we infer integrity from
the fact that we trust
whoever is keeping the record.
So, you deduce integrity
from responsibility
and you say, if I know
the names of the person
that handled the document over time,
if I know he's responsible
for keeping the record,
if there are annotations
related to changes,
but technical changes and any other kind,
if there is a digital
signature, et cetera,
if I have these elements, then I can say,
I can infer integrity.
Which is the quality of
being complete and unaltered
in all essential respects.
And we have never been fussy about it.
So, if you had a document
with a hole in the middle,
or yellowish, or with
the ink fading aways,
or with the corners
burnt, you wouldn't say,
"Oh, it has lost integrity
so we don't want it.
"It's no longer authentic."
You would say it's good enough, right?
As long as I know what it is.
Well, is that different in
the digital environment?
Let's see.
Loss of integrity of an analog document.
Can still read it.
Still manage.
Still okay, you still
have the same document.
Now, a digital document.
If the original bits
are 101, it is a five.
If it is 110, it is a six.
If it is 011, it is a three.
Same bits, different value.
Why?
Because the order counts.
Not just the number.
So, you can see that we are
not talking about fading away,
we are talking about losing
bits we lose the record.
Because we are talking
about data integrity
based on bitwise integrity,
the fact that the data are
not modified intentionally
or accidentally.
The bits are in a complete
and unaltered state.
So, a small change in the
bits means a different value
on the screen and a different action.
How do we protect them?
Well, intentional
alteration is preventable
through permission and access
control, access privileges,
or through Checksum and HASH Algorithms.
Accidental alteration is preventable
through special hardware and software.
But the problem is that we
have to be able to determine
that alteration has happened,
most of the times we don't really know.
And so, what do we do?
Do we go and check the logs?
Yes, on a regular way we could.
But in fact, we have to infer integrity
till such time when it is questioned,
and then you have the logs to control it.
Otherwise, there is no other way.
And as regards copies, because
we live in a copy world,
in a world of copies, duplication
integrity is important.
It's the process.
So given a document, a digital document,
you must be sure that
the process of copying it
doesn't change it.
Often this change is linked to time,
that is, today wouldn't
but tomorrow it would,
the process that you carry out.
Because it depends on what
else is in the system.
And of course we do
duplication all the time,
but not necessarily
the output is the same.
When we talk about a copy,
we talk about a selective duplicate.
A selective duplicate is
never the same as the original
because you can only
copy what you can see,
and on paper it was very easy
because you could see the metadata.
You can't see the metadata
in the digital environment,
or other things like the metadata.
There is rarely
confirmation of completeness
and there is an incomplete
picture of the environment.
The image is a forensic duplication,
is a bit by bit
reproduction of everything.
But you may not want to have
that sort of duplication
to deal with
because then you would
have to maintain it,
all those parts like
swap space, slack space,
ambient data, et cetera, that are useless.
You don't want to.
So, how do you have an
authentic duplication?
You have an authentic
duplication when in some way
you can maintain a native format.
Now, over time we have been used to PDF
for delivering page-based documents.
We use for preservation PDF/A
because it allows to
maintain all the fonts.
PDF/A-2 increases accessibility,
but PDF/A-3 is where we're heading now.
Because what it does is to provide you
the service of PDF/A-1, that
is, you see the document
as you chose permanently on the screen,
but it can embed all the previous formats.
So, it is what is used
now to address the issues
of obsolescence and of
readability and usability.
It gives you the main display document
in a stable and fixed way,
and the metadata set can be
stored in the dumb data sections
to ensure authenticity.
So, any concern about best
evidence and data integrity
can be addressed, embedding
the bit-stream of the source
within this document.
So, this is what now is considered to be
the copy that is appropriate
mostly against obsolescence
and for the purposes of best
evidence in a court of law.
The process through which we do it
must follow the principle
of non-interference,
which means that the method you use
is not changing anything.
Or the principle of
identifiable interference:
if it is changing anything
you say what it is,
you can identify it.
I don't think we have the time
to talk about digital signature.
I have five minutes, we have the time.
There is a difference between authenticity
and authentication that is key.
Because authenticity is a
quality of the document,
either it's authentic or it is.
Authentication is a
declaration that the document
is authentic in that specific moment,
but not necessarily the next day.
So, today we use digital
signature for authentication
and digital signature is not
a signature, it is a seal.
Because it is an attachment
to a complete document
that already has its own signature
or whatever it needs to have.
It's complete as is.
It verifies the origin of the document,
certifies the intactness of the document,
it makes authorship and
ownership indisputable,
that is, non-repudiation.
The digital signature,
talking about copies,
is said to provide
incontrovertible mechanism
for verifying the authenticity
of digital objects.
Right, accept.
What it is that it verifies?
That the person who claims
to have sent the document
is in fact the person who
claims, who is, right?
And it verifies that the document
that was put into the system and sent
has not been altered.
It does not verify that
the copy is actually
a copy of the document
that it claims to be.
So, we're back to the same thing.
All this mechanical
system, they just prove you
that what you receive is
what was sent by the person.
But that person is sending
you the copy of the document
that she or he is claiming to be something
that you can't prove,
certainly not with the digital signature.
Besides, digital signatures are good
for ensuring authenticity of documents
as they move across space
from a system to another.
Not across time.
Because it becomes obsolete
before the document
to which it is attached and
cannot really be preserved.
And memory institutions
are not maintaining them.
So, what's better to use?
A chain of legitimate custody
is ground for inferring authenticity.
The digital chain of
custody is the least of all
that has been done to the
record for the document
from beginning to end.
And a declaration on the
trustworthiness of the system
reading which the document exists.
So especially the court's now saying,
"If I can trust that nobody
has interfered with the system,
"so I will believe that the document
"and the system are okay."
It's an inference again.
So, we get to the main slide here.
Involuntary secondary permanence.
Where?
Now, by now you know
we have already lost track of everything.
The copies are uncontrollable.
They're everywhere.
They're distributed, they're redundant,
there're lots of authenticated copies
for preservation, et cetera.
And we don't really want to keep them,
but we don't know where to find them
in order to destroy them so we give up.
That's the situation.
Except it's not much of a problem.
If we have an in-house system,
if everything is inside our
building and our servers,
it clogs the system, but
really is not such a problem.
What if the documents are not with us?
What if the documents are in the custody
of some cloud provider,
of some other third party?
How do we prove the
trustworthiness of the copies
that they have and they control?
That's why we created the
fourth phase of InterPARES,
InterPARES Trust or Itrust.
This is the fourth phase
of the research project.
Its goal is to generate
theoretical and methodological frameworks
to support the development of networks
of policies, procedures,
regulations, standards
and legislation concerning
digital documents
entrusted to the Internet.
It is funded for five years.
It includes about 300
partners from six continents
and 35 countries,
and this is in order to ensure
that whatever we generate
is consistent across.
The reason is that the
documentary memory of the world
is increasingly in the cloud
because archives and libraries
have to acquire material
that already exists in the cloud.
They have to provide access
from everywhere to anybody.
The systems that are required
by ISO are not affordable.
The knowledge required to
deal with this material
is not affordable.
Many believe that protection
equals preservation,
which is not true, but under this illusion
this is what they do.
But mostly we are confronted
with a generational change
where the younger people, post-1981,
they integrate public and
private, they co-author things,
there is crowdsourcing,
there is co-owning, sharing,
working from home, bringing
your own device to work,
and the material is on
a variety of clouds.
Convergence of media.
If I tell you that I will
meet you at 5 o'clock
I send you a Google map, right?
I don't give you an address.
Constant connectivity,
liquid communication,
and enormous amount of
ephemeral material generated.
What is its characteristics?
They can be viewed differently
based on choice of browser,
application, user preferences.
So it is impossible to say which one
is the authoritative version.
Unless you have the authoritative version
in your in-house system.
Metadata may be constructed by anybody
to manipulate the behavior of the system,
not just to describe it.
If the goal is communication,
you have a specific way
of having the document to self-destruct.
But if you don't do that nobody
is going to destroy them.
When Google promised to eliminate
with international court,
you know the verdict to
eliminate the documents
related to a specific situation,
he cut the links, he didn't
eliminate the documents,
so documents are there.
So, if you use a different search
rather than the name of the person
your search copyright in a
specific kind of articles,
you'll find all articles again.
So, everything is there,
it will never go away.
So never put up there anything
you don't want to be used
against your grandchildren
in the next 100 years.
If the goal is memory,
now people create their
own digital archives
out of documents taken from everywhere.
The primary challenges,
very quickly, are the reuse,
the creation of derivative works.
The sharing, movement of material
from one circle of people
to another, constantly numerable copies;
employees collectively create bodies
of interlinked material.
Government of Canada
Wikipedia: 150 departments,
250 thousand employees
create documents together.
And so, nobody knows to which
agency each document belongs.
And when it's been completed or generated.
Location independence.
The jurisdiction of the entity
responsible for preservation
is different from the
jurisdiction of the entity
responsible for storage.
And so, involuntary permanence is rising
to a whole other level.
You know what the cloud is
so we don't need to say.
The issues obviously are: transparency;
ownership, authorship, creatorship;
retention and disposition; loss
of context; trustworthiness;
jurisdiction; and ethics.
So, traditionally we deal
with this with policies,
training, model agreements.
But that's not enough.
We need much more,
because many or any copy
can only replace an original
by having the authority
and the effectiveness of an original.
And we don't know that any of this does.
So stay tuned!
Thank you.
(applause)